what's the weirdest thing that you ever
put in your mouth like you guys do that
eating that that that have you ever seen
they this weirdy Fallon uh usually we've
never had a sexual encounter just just
to say that I'm not talking about pennis
um oh I'm talking about what they do if
you I thought every bile cheesecake I
mean if we're going to eat something
really gross it's we we've hired a chef
to make it like our mythical kitchen
makes the worst things in the most
amazing way have you ever got
sick um
surprisingly well I chugged a liter of
vinegar and you shouldn't do that the
weirdest thing you put in your mouth
100y old coconut oh yeah who's saving a
coconut for a hundred years it was
canned coconut two people did it for 50
years each they they sell it on eBay so
we we buy old food old stuff on eBay and
just fascinating you know you pay $100
for this thing and I just you know it
was seemed like it would be fun to I
didn't swallow it but I I there could
have been botulism there's all kinds of
things that yeah you could have died it
was an impulsive decision I know so I've
watched that and that's the question the
question that I had was they have these
tastes of icky stuff and that's been one
of their we eat a lot of stuff they do
and I thought just like you could you
could die I also like I mean there's
things that you've put in your mouth
that could actually kill you I mean it's
it's beyond funny I probably wouldn't do
that again look at you I did not do that
I wouldn't yeah um yeah now that you're
not so religious you figure you're not
as safe man I think this might be over
when I die this is stretch this out as
much as I can yeah you guys are great uh
GMM is the is the main show that I'm
aware I have a good myth mythical
morning every on YouTube and you guys
shoot that every day and then you have
like this after show days a week and
then there's yeah there's good mythical
moas you can just click over and so you
can spend like 40 minutes with with us
every the thing that we're most excited
about creatively right now uh that so
we're going to talk it up is we actually
rekindled the OG rtin Link channel the
channel that started in 2006 we it's
gone through different iterations but
we've we kind of stopped playing the hey
let's go across town and Pitch somebody
on a show or let's write a screenplay
and we said let's take all these
creative ideas that we've been having
let's just put them directly into
content on YouTube so we've we've done
about six videos so far this year we're
getting about one a month so Jeremy put
the link you'll give us the link the
link will be down below yeah so that's
just basically youtube.com/ rlink so
that's the original Channel each video
is a standalone Odyssey into a seemingly
mundane premise that will surprise you
with some yeah I also some weirdness
heard from the guys in the back that you
recently sold smos is that true so yeah
back I'll make the long story short we
had a strange opportunity when things
sort of fell apart for them they were
owned by a different company uh and then
years ago we were we were trying to give
them a place to just do their business
but ended up being this incredible
opportunity for us to buy them and kind
of uh let Ian who was in charge of smos
continue to retain you know control uh
and then Anthony because they were a
longtime internet Duo Ian and Anthony go
way back you know even before us we had
him on he was telling us that story and
so they got back together and said that
they wanted smos back we were like well
we we only did this to begin with to
help you guys out because we loved you
guys and we believed in what you're
doing so yeah let's work out a deal and
so that closed a couple months ago to
you also have this thing where you
develop you have like this $5
million is that a fund and you get these
two you just launched uh there's these
two girls that the Sor girls yes fellow
Canadians yes yes so what a lot of
interior design it's like uh HDTV for
yeah well the whole point call the
mythical accelerator is essentially uh
investing in a Creator who wants to
build a company similar to the one that
we've built right they they have they
want to kind of leave a legacy they want
to build a media company so we give them
some money to get some equity in their
business and then we give them the
advice and all the lessons that we've
learned over the time we have a team
that's committed to that and kind of
work them through all those business
decisions uh we've got three people in
that program now and we're very slowly
in very particular about how we expand
but it's a pretty small sort of Boutique
[Music]
thing